season two i'm so excited girls five eva
i mean you guys are in album mode as i
think this is what this whole series is
about this season yes is the lyrics
going to be as insane as season one
because we get introduced to momentum in
the first episode
more so more so insane but somehow they
just are so brilliant
jeff
richmond meredith scardino
sara bareilles they make these songs
where if you really read the lyrics
they're insane and hilarious but you're
listening to the song and you want to
put it on a playlist you love the song
you know
yeah the
at the beep song
is there's a song this season called at
the beep and honestly a tear like you're
a jerker it will bring you a tear
and then
you like actually listen closer and
you're like yeah
interesting okay oh no really
good yeah did you think season one was
gonna hit everybody loves it the critics
love it the audience you think it was
gonna be such a hit
we were hoping that people would enjoy
it because we loved making it so much
but
when when the critics really loved it
and when i got
i was surprised i i was there you guys i
knew because he was gonna say that
no i was surprised i knew that there
would be peop some people that really
love it because it comes from that world
of 30 rock and and just that whole taste
of comedy that's like boom boom boom
funny funny funny
and so i knew there would be fans of it
but i didn't really anticipate how much
love would be thrown at it and i was
absolutely thrilled and surprised also
but like really really thrilled at how
many people were not only watching it
but like really appreciating it and and
being touched by it too which i loved
because we were touched by it yeah i
think that for me sometimes i think that
for me sometimes it's hard uh
when i'm in the process of it making
something
um i think that and
like to think about
what the outcome could be or what the
people's response to it could be
and i think that
that is one of the reasons like i think
people get in their heads sometimes when
they make make stuff creatively because
they're thinking about they're
anticipating what people might want to
see or what they're going to see and
really this was the first time i think
in
a lot well this is reacting wise this is
like one of the first times where i felt
like i went into it and i was like i'm
just along for the ride i'm so happy to
be here i'm gonna like do some wild
swings
and like if people don't get it they
don't get it i had the best time ever
well also season season one was deep in
the pandemic and we just all didn't even
know when anything would even come out
like is there going to even be a tv
season like that it was such an unsure
time so no one had a whole bunch of
optimism in terms of like when or where
but when it did come out and people
loved it i was thrilled yeah and i think
that's what it is when you say the word
love that friendship you guys have on
the set the chemistry is so beautiful
but it got me thinking about you know
you guys being on this journey for
yourselves in this career who was that
person
for you that was there for you to cheer
you on
and say you're going to make it
oh uh
you cut out for a minute there are you
saying of the of in our real lives who
was there yeah like when you realized
who was that person that held on to you
and was your cheerleader
oh i mean i i i think for me it was my
my co-workers you know like at snl when
you'd have a terrible week and then
you'd have someone that's really close
to you come in at five in the morning
when you're in tears looking at a sketch
you thought would be funny and now is a
piece of
and they come over and they're like you
know what
it today does not define you this
we can throw this in the garbage and you
can just start again and come up with
something else you always had that
person that would lift you up and of
course my great family and and and close
friends always would lift me up
yeah i mean i've been
lucky enough
well i you know
it's a long it's a long journey
if you're lucky yeah you know
like what do they say life is either too
long or too short
and like i you know throughout my career
i've had many different incarnations
of
it and
me
and
the world um
i've had the same agent lori bartlett
since i was 20
wow 20 years old since i was 20 years
old
and you know i remember laurie once
saying to me after i didn't get some
huge job i was up for when i was in my
20s and was like super bummed about it
like
this it's gonna
it's gonna be someone i don't know who
it is if it's like a big director if
it's a writer like someone is
going to just
get get it get you just get it
and like
what are the chances that that person
was tina fey i had no idea that that was
who it was gonna be i was like judd are
you ready to make me a movie star yet
like no
you know what i mean and then and like
tina has really been that for me and
lori
yes i'm like so grateful that i've been
surrounded by such incredible strong
women who work in this industry and
they're really the ones that i've looked
to in those times who've been like
sorry yeah
let's just like let's just move for you
know like keep going
so this is this your moment then are you
saying this is the highlight right now
for your career having tina fey in your
life and having lori and having this
moment and doing the show well no i mean
i just think that i mean tina's been
there now for me for the last like six
years you know
i basically only work with her
she produced my talk show i did a pilot
with her years ago she had me come be on
cami
schmidt like i you know
no i think that
listen i think that i've had
quite
an incredible
journey in my career and
all of the shows that i look back on
that i've gotten to be a part of all of
the incredible brilliant people that
i've been able to work with i'm i'm
stunned i'm floored that like my first
job was freaks and geeks that i got to
be honest yeah
dawson's creek and like all of these
things it's wild
but here we are
here we are and you know the other thing
with this show is that it's focusing on
social media and
being on tick tock and being you know
you found on tick tock and being
celebrated are you guys on tick tock do
you find yourself scrolling through it
i scroll and watch it my wife really
enjoys it and she watches a lot but
she's she's figured out a way to
favorite things so she gets what she
wants to watch
and i'll just have like bizarre times
where it'll just be like memorials for
dogs like it'll just be like
dog funerals and it'll be like 20 dog
fan rolls in a row and i'm like
the moment the dog is dying like
literally things where i'm like what i
mean i know that i got flagged for dogs
because i'm you know a dog loving les
but like come on like i never asked i
never wanted the dead dogs you know so
it would just be these horrible sad
things but then sometimes god i enjoy it
i have some there are some people and
kids on there that i love so much that
are so funny to me and so sweet
um so yes i enjoy tic tac it's it feels
like a lighter fluffier thing than than
other social media to me and for me i'm
like not really allowed to have it
because i have a 13 year old and i have
to allow them to
have their own social media
but like birdie shows me tic tocs and
i like love the things that i see that
they share with me
and then they show me some like wild
ones and i'm like
that's insane and totally false and
birdie's like i know right
um but i think it's like a good
opportunity as a parent to talk to your
kids about critical thinking
and about uh actually
uh doing your own research um which is
like becomes like so taken and turned
into this whole other meaning but um
you know but
not everything and this is like another
thing that i try to explain to bernie
too like not everything can be boiled
down to 30 seconds like like life
is
complicated and nuanced and
lives in a space between and so tick
tock is like so wonderful for some
things and like breaking it down and
like giving you facts and whatever and
then sometimes i'm like that is a great
point and also
let's go over here and see if we can
hold this for two and a half minutes so
it's like you know i think that if
parents
don't engage with their then they're
doing themselves a disservice if they're
like uh i don't know dancing i can't get
behind that but do you know how much i
have learned
from tick-tock
i mean i've learned how many dogs die
well and i'm sorry for that do you want
birdie to come over and try to help your
algorithm
i need algorithm help okay